welcome to this video this will be a
another part thought part or third
episode of this opening focus serious
chess openings uncovered and this time
I'll have a look and present an overview
of the classical Kings Indian main line
which is the following one d4 Knight f6
c4g six nights is really seven and we
got a King's Indian and by far the most
popular line by white it's not a three
and Bishop e2 which has some the
classical variation this is defined by
putting a knight on f3 and a bishop on
e2 there are alternatives of course
white can also play h3 for instance
which is not exactly the classical but
Bishop e2 and Castle system the main
line now black plays b5 and castles he
an important alternative is Bishop e3
the legal rich variation which is also
very popular and also there's d5 the
Petrosian variation which is yeah a bit
of a forgotten line it's not so popular
anymore but still quite interesting for
white but I'll have a look at the
absolute mainland which is castles yeah
black of course has multitude of firm
possibilities but the main move and also
the sharpest move is 96 which
intensifies the pressure on white center
so white cannot yam ignore the dis
pressure she cannot make a nothing move
let's for example just for argument's
sake what would make a move like h3
which does nothing then like him come up
with this kind of tactic
and win upon so yeah white must react
him and he usually goes with d5 97 and
this is some the absolute main position
of the Kings Indian probably I haven't
had checked it but this is suddenly
within the King's Indian if you would
check for positions after eight moved
with white to move on move nine this is
some with absolute certainty the most
popular position and yeah this is some
in a way understandable as it is White's
most straightforward way to develop so
Knight f3 we should be to castles and d5
was yeah I'm not exactly forced to close
to this so um what does some happening
in this position the pawn structure is
the most important thing here that
defines the upcoming plans in the middle
game White has got this advanced pawn
that he's got this pawn chain which
defines his space advantage on the Queen
side so White has some the Queen side SM
the natural place to yet to initiate
play and advance so um this often
involves the pawn push c5 attacking the
d6 pawn the base of the chain so c5
sometimes supported by B form and also
that can be M a text based on piece play
with not b5 and some point so why it's
natural um yeah area of the board is the
Queen side of course and for blankets
yeah the King side as this kind of
confirmation I get rid of the all the
stuff this kind of confirmation suggests
that blacks a pawn break that he needs
to go for and yeah this is really almost
mandatory it's hard to play this opening
without this move you need to go with f5
attacking White's
he for porn and
depending on circumstances like
sometimes even pushes this upon further
and also uses the other pawns so it
wants us all to spawn some yet right in
front of the king but this isn't really
an issue blacks King is not not weakened
anyway in any way so you can in advance
these pawns yeah and actually here white
has some quite a number of moves and all
those moves are trying to address the
upcoming middle game plans in slightly
different ways the traditional main
mafia you must take into account that
this position is really only known for
about 60 years
I mean no one played this kind of
opening before yeah world war ii it was
really introduced with the gather
generation after after the war in Russia
that was Ghulam bronze Bronstein
they've got glee garage recently he
recently died also was a huge expert on
this opening and back then the absolute
main line was 91 and it's still a very
important line today
probably not the main move but this is
often dictated also by fashion so why
would white play this retreat 91 yeah it
has some a very M direct idea this way
wide prevents black from playing Knight
h5 and f5
as white of course simply if we'd known
that h5 you could simply win a pawn and
this is not okay for like just giving
away the pawn like that so black cannot
play this active knight move to prepare
a 5 if he wants to play a 5 he needs to
move the knight to a more passive Square
like 800 or to d7
so this is one idea of this night who
saw that black needs to play em yeah a
passive night move the other idea is
that it clears the f-pawn we can see
this in the following line that's a
black place 97 to prepare a 5 so on if
white would play um let's say Bishop 93
now f5 then you have the opportunity to
play f3 and so you can support the
center this is also main reason why the
f3 Knight is moved in this kind of
positions so that you can give support
to d4 pawn cross the night which has
been transferred to d3 here also has
other ideas
it can go to f2 for example which can be
a very good square for the knight
because a dumb control it's the g4
square but that's got not done ahead of
ourselves so 91 97 here's the major
parting of the ways white can now decide
if he wants to play Bishop b3 and he
should do this exactly now or if he
wants to place the bishop on d2 and go
for a different setup there should be 3
is the most aggressive move as it points
towards the Queen side the disadvantage
of this movement after F 5 F 3 F form
like winds the tempo no g5 or h5 and so
black has one a tempo in this this
fashion with F form and this has been
for a very long time considered to be a
really really bad variation for what up
to the the seventies I would say even
Fischer in I know not quite sure if it I
think it even was in 60 memory of Google
games he wrote that yeah that this
attack is worked out to a mate for black
so black delivering mate and Fischer was
the kings in yep
of course that's that's not true it was
a very simplistic way to see it um yeah
and it was really Viktor Korchnoi who
sort of resurrected this variation and
began to play it starting in the 70s and
80s and he had huge success with this
and his games are absolutely fantastic
in this opening so if you want to take
up this without studying course noise
games it would be would be rather weird
because he's really the godfather of
this set up so this is some very much
yeah and the essential form of the
classical Kings Indian where white is
trying to kill black on the Queen side
and black is trying to do the exact
opposite on the King side delivering
mate and well as mentioned white has
invested a whole muth here putting the
the bishop on f2 um black has got got an
f4 with tempo and even if you consider
g4 g3 this can be another tempo on this
Bishop so um this leads to absolute
super sharp play which can only be
recommended for white players who have
really got strong nerves and defending
or kill the king because black will get
something against the king but you need
to do defend accurately yeah in this
position now white even has some has a
multitude of possibilities caution or
some original innovation was Knight b5
which now I think has been defused by b6
there are also moves like a four which
was caught you know as second try the
idea to play a five sometimes even a six
and also to support night b5 so that
after Knight b5 b6 you can immediately
play e5 if was also an absolute mainline
um even nowadays um there's also the
interesting move rook c1 which has been
played a lot
in recent years the ideas to even
sacrifice a pawn with c5 serve that
place something like this white will
play this very aggressive move
so after details you can even play P
form and it's a this kind of position is
simply horrible for black so he needs to
take what the night and then you play
before something like this and you
sacrifice a pawn for lots of pressure on
the C file probably this is capable Ike
but it's not easy at all to play this
has got the advantage that this Knight
is stranded on a six that cannot help
you out there on the kingside somewhere
what has some other options though it
can also play Knight d3 and also before
so not completely completely out of the
out of the picture so this is the kind
of line that you should play if you
really think that you can kill black on
the Queen side and yeah that you're a
good enough defender to not get mated as
black of course um yeah you're you're
running the yeah you're pretty much sure
that your Queen side will fall apart so
you need to get counter play as quickly
as possible
Black has got lots of ideas and it's
really a matter of the exact move
Odyssey a let's say a for for example
black has a multitude of moves you can
go a five there's even the weird-looking
move a six with the idea to cover b5 and
then play rook f6 h 628 Queen to h5 and
this is super crude but it's it's
dangerous you can easily M really
quickly with this kind of kind of a
technique of course black can also
simply ignore this and get on with his
own play
so 96 h5 and so on
so on it's super complicated but what I
would like to stress you that as white
you should only play this if you have
strong nerves with defending your king I
had to look at this variation more than
more than one time and at the end always
decided that I cannot play this because
I simply hated to have my King attacked
so so directly um it's a still a very
principled way to combat the Kings
Indian and when you're for the black
players if you're not comfortable facing
such a line then then you shouldn't play
this this kind of opening I mean you're
positionally busted on the Queen side
you need to be aware of that and play a
huge counter take on the King side it's
super sharp but um this is the nature of
this opening and this is um this Bishop
III line is absolutely the sharpest that
white can try it's the the quickest way
to try to bust the the Queen side but it
also as mentioned runs the risk of a
huge counter-attack because you spend
too much time white here also has them
in another option and this is to play
over the bishop only to d2 to avoid this
temple gain um this cannon run as
follows that's a 93 f5 Bishop d2 Knight
f6 attacking you form f3 and now black
plays f4 to close the King side and
prepare g5 edgy form so it's a it's a
similar point structure but note that
white has the bishop here and he didn't
yeah give up a tempo with Bishop e3 to
f2 so the bishop ISM is more passive
here but you've gained time in a way so
that why does some now I'm able to play
c5 here the knight was put on d3
to support this move note that in this
kind of setup it's not a good idea to
play lots of pawn moves here this is a
common mistake that that players some of
all kinds of levels make in this
position that they want to make further
pawn moves on the Queen side this is
really not not the way to go you need to
try to infiltrate on the C file as
quickly as possible and those pawn moves
don't really help you so much you can
move your pawns but only in a position
where you're already basically busted
like it's not something that you should
do now yeah let's follow what happens c5
g5 and here for for a long time the
usual continuation was to take on d6 we
should look at this first
kake's takes and ruku c1 yeah here black
has the typical can of maneuver 96 the
end of K and F Knight v5 black can play
rook to to f7 covering c7 here from the
side so that white cannot enter and and
this is a typical regrouping also black
will play Bishop to f8 even covering the
six and then look to g7 supporting the
the jeep on push hm here can here white
can play multiple moves Quincy to us as
a possibility getting this into play
again so White's main idea is to play on
the C file and he can also play Knight
f2 to play against this g4 advance so
the knight on f2 is covering the g4
square so this Knight maneuver here
nighty 1 d3 first was designed to
support c5 and then drop back to f2 to
control G form um important ideas here
also are let's um
and look at this another way this is not
the main I just want to show the idea
Knight f2 to support G form and white
very often uses the rook here on the
third-ranked to defend the king side so
that after g4 you can take and then
swing the rook over this is also typical
idea yeah this is some pretty much the
oldest line in the in the mainline Kings
in yet however in recent years um let's
say last three or four years there has
been a new discovery in the slides which
is rather interesting the idea is not to
take immediately on d6 but to play rook
G Roxy one first the ideas if black
continues like this not b5 look f7 so
what simply hasn't had yeah didn't take
yet here White has the funny move Bishop
to a5 simply young yeah attacking this
pawn guns threatening to take on d6 and
this is some rather tricky line I'm not
quite sure that if black has already
yeah yeah found found a great antidote
to this so probably he has but it's just
otherwise people wouldn't play the Kings
Indian anymore because black doesn't
have so many options before that
probably needs to play b6 and then then
it done continues um okay this is an
interesting idea to look at for for the
white play and in general this kind of
line with Bishop d2 I think it can be
recommended it's a bit out of fashion
actually and this can be a good idea for
y to go along those classical lines as
black players have so many other stuff
too so much other stuff to look at to
prepare something that this kind of old
forgotten line can be a good idea black
of course needs to know his
and setups here because this is simply a
such a principled line that you should
know what to do
yeah this is our other two main branches
of the the night me1 line so the corn or
line with Bishop III and the Bishop d2
line there are some others I cannot go
into into every line one possibility for
example is is this which looks we added
for a site this advance of the G porn
but this is quite interesting it's sort
of preempts blacks play on the on the
kingside so there are a multitude of
minor lines but those are the two main
main ideas with 91 another main move
which is similar in nature but still
owns the different is 92 similar in one
way that it prevents this Knight h5 idea
again and it also over protects a form
difference though a very important
difference is it blocks this bishop so
on it's not exactly a move that speeds
up your development of course it's a
very close position so the development
is not as essential as in an open
position where piece players some is
dominant but still it it's somewhat
clumsy looking move in a way I'm still
perfectly playable of course the idea
why why it puts the knight exactly on d2
is the idea to put it on c4 later so if
you want to play c5 Knight c4 and then
attack this the space of the chain um
this can be shown um most directly if
black plays something like ninety seven
let's say deform f5 and then white can
even play c5 ignoring the fact that this
is protected
unprotected on c5 like what let's just
put it on the board like what grab this
this is too much you got too much
pressure and in the center but then
black would play probably this and then
let's say f3 f1 94 this is what you want
to do with white by putting the knight
on D - you want the knight on c4
attacking this pawn so this is in fact
the he had the sharpest way for her
black to respond to 92 by simply
ignoring all this and getting ahead with
the the King side play um yeah this is
some align that in recent years Hikaru a
Nakamura has played as black more than
once and with quite some success even
it's a very risky as this is basically
yeah I mean you're simply giving away
the Queen side and you know you'll get
completely busted on the Queen side and
you need to deliver mate everything else
for black is simply not acceptable you
need to get this attack going um I
probably am continuing something like
this something like this and yeah you
see that white has a huge buildup on the
crew on the Queen side someone black has
some really a yes to hurry on the King
side it's a super sharp plane if you
don't mind the risk and buff then you
can you can go for this the good thing
about this as from from from blacks
point of view is if you look at this
position and you you simply as mentioned
ignore this and let white play his stuff
um if you don't mind this line then you
also have after before which is probably
the main move nowadays you can also
simply ignore this as it's simply
poses white doesn't have anything else
really then getting into the kind of
line that I just showed let's say c5 f5
and white will probably transpose into
this Nakamura even got his positions
mostly from nine before and not nine
ninety two so this would be a way to
yeah sort of
yeah kill two birds with one stone
but after ninety two black has besides
those ultra aggressive moves ninety
eight is similar in nature also ignoring
the Queen side White has a black has a
couple of more prophylactic he moves the
main move probably is a five which
simply prevents before from the charm
beam and white um yeah has more than one
option I think a three is a so the main
move web-like am now can choose mostly
between Knight to d7 and f5 I can play
Bishop to g7 which is more of a
defensive move the idea is also to play
a four block the Queen side and yeah
this is servant right what what I played
s black when I still played the Kingston
you know is like this is very flexible
kind of move it's always funny what the
computer gives in this kind of position
if you and the computer of course if you
would have this position in in a match
game and the computer would play a human
not another engine it would play out of
the opening books but here Houdini
proudly wants to play nine f3 which is
complete complete nonsense it's it's
funny and computer so absolutely has no
idea about the Kings Indian okay it
gives wide advantage of course complete
titli insane I mean after Knight f3 for
example I just play a four and have a
good position I mean black is just
better no question
alright and but just a slight digression
wide usually place a move like B 3 and
then prepares before slowly and this is
a sort of mixed game yet so it's a
little bit of maneuvering it might get
sharper later but it's not the kind of
yeah gung-ho kingside attacking style
which you could get with 9897 still
black is far more solid you're not
risking to yet to get blown away quickly
so this is more um
yes let's say more of a sophisticated
way to to play the king's engineer with
a 5 also possible as c5 which is not bad
at all it simply blocks the c4 c5 idea
but it's a bit passive yeah admittedly
um white very often it very often can
get something like this this kind of
position where white is always very
slightly better it's not not a huge
problem for black but it is slightly
passive you cannot really get something
going on the kingside on any actions
with f5 white probably will take and in
the long run
white has ideas like this of course not
now it's double protected even on a5 but
you can go here you can also attack d6
in some way and why does rather flexible
IAM how am also handles to the king side
so it's a slightly better form for white
so after 92 I think black should think
about play em ups play a 5
and probably we should be 74 for
positional game now d7 is also sharp
it's not as sharp as the slide where
black ignores all this if you really
don't care what your queen side and just
want to want to hack away then 97 f5 or
so is fine you should know the risk that
you're running but it certainly leads to
very uncompromising play yeah the white
player I also looked at this line for
for quite some time over the years some
because I'd like the the the kind of
slower setups with a 5 and so on I mean
this is the kind of position that you
can play with with both colors and it's
it's interesting and complicated why why
I didn't play this simply am as why this
this this kind of stuff that Nakamura is
playing where he simply gives away the
Queen side and attacks up on the King
side I always hate it when my King has
attacked so it was never my line so um
after this you need to be aware of 97-98
it gets very uncompromising and it's um
it's it's tough it will be a very tough
game very interesting though playing
this is for bots or for both sides so um
this is some 92 and yeah now to the the
most popular move nowadays which is
before yeah before the bayonet attack
um what some yeah always a sight line up
to the only 90s really in the early 90s
um there's been a discovery which really
am put this line into into the forefront
of chess theory and practice and this is
some that after 9h 5 which is the main
move
even even nowadays after night h 5y them
doesn't really need to fear the move
Knight to f4 up to this point it was
believed that white must play g3 here
too to cover the sum in the square but
in the early 90s people recognized that
rookie woman is a very interesting move
here the idea being that if black plays
Knight f4 which is so not particularly
good even you can play Bishop f1 tucking
this bishop away and not allowing black
- yeah - to take it that in this
position black can cannot really play a5
which looks like the normal way to
proceed but it's it's simply not
playable you can take here captures and
E 5 and this position is is very very
problematic from like why does measure
through in the Santa is reason it's got
the great development and you will even
be able to probably play c5 Bishop c4
and all kinds of stuff this is also also
in the mix gap like it's a terrible
terrible fashion here simply not a not a
playable line so this is the the very
basic idea of the rook move that Knight
f4 isn't really such a great threat here
and this wasn't recognized before let's
say 1990 1991 um nowadays f5 is played
here not a form as as mentioned not so
great f5 and now we see one idea of this
this whole setup with before where this
Knight hasn't moved and this is Knight
to g5 if you don't move the knight or do
you wanna you want you even have the
chance to jump to to g5 and this is some
a very interesting positional concept
like now I will most likely retreat
to have six and now you have to slide on
g5 and yeah what is not actually doing
them
um yeah one main point of the snide is
that it and one day we will go to b6 and
it will get taken and white will have a
pawn on e6 which is often yeah a very
double-edged affair to have such a pawn
it it can be very strong there but it
can be is also easily yeah get lost as
black can attack it with Quincy a 26 um
let's just put something on the board
let's say I'll go Bishop e3 if black
would play h6 white um goes here
and this is quite interesting white now
it tends to take on f5 to detect the the
b7 pawn so I'm black must react to this
you can play something like this for
example after which white would go b5 so
this is a very very interesting um
positional struggle here in the send to
the center this Pournami yeah can get
lost at some point but white has very
active pieces this is a bishop at the
moment is not doing more than look at
its own porn but it can always take at
the right moment while also has Bishop
e3 as a possibility to attack the d6
pawn can intensify the pressure here so
um this is some yeah an interesting
active position for white the difference
between this kind of setup to to Knight
d2 or 91 is that the play is mainly
happening in the center center is
sometimes really opening up and it's not
a strict race situation in the bishop
you want a 91 or 92 line sometimes it's
really a kind of race where white puts
everything on the Queen side
tries to to win the game then black
pushes his King side here does some much
more ya complicated and and not so
straightforward play this is just one
possible possible line there are there
are others white can also go here which
had been played often and black even we
chance to to age 5 p.m.
um yeah and it continues for for quite a
while in fact I'm the latest kind of
fashion is introduced by Kramnik who is
basically the yet the world's number one
expert in this line is to play g3 the
old move and then after f5 95 9 f6 to
play Bishop f3 this is a new idea or
let's say yeah it's not not new but it
has been played in one or two games from
from from some of the 90s but the ideas
it's similar to the rookie one set up
with so now but why does play g3 and
Kramnik recently won a very nice game
with this with this line against tree
shock in them I'm not quite sure time
memorial I think it was the Tom Memorial
um he won a very nice game man with this
line and this is similar but also
slightly different g3 of course allows
y2 to drop back the bishop at some point
and the rukon f once the protects f2 but
in general it's the same concept as
shown before this Knight g5 e6 basically
kills all blacks play in the on the
kingside like will not have an automatic
attack there and play will happen more
in the center which will open up
after before in setup night age five
like also has another continuation which
is playable this is a five after which
white um responds by taking a plane
Bishop III which even can lead to two
the same kind of position usually it
continues in this way b6 a four and now
black can go like you think every any
place with a knight as some has been
played or something like this so black
has invested a bit of time with a five
and B six to to slow down White's play
on the Queen side and now will intense
to play a5 later
I think this line I mean this a five
line in general nowadays has the
reputation to be a little bit better for
white but it's still fairly solid for
black so it can be it can be an idea to
to play like this some if you're black
if you want to avoid the the main path
with 9h five and as mentioned when I
explained a bit of about ninety two
after before black can also ignore all
this and continue his play this kind of
yeah the Nakamura variation so to say
which could rise like this also after
nine before so this is the the way for
black cam that I can recommend to play
if you don't mind the huge risk and but
also you you simply a.m. you need to
invest less time as you can play this
line against before in 92 so are there
other moves here yeah there are all
kinds of stuff has been tried but
they're not so theoretically important
um Bishop g5 has been played a couple of
times
after which black can he has got more
than one idea always like to play h6
takes takes and then it often continues
like this before and I always liked this
idea 98 Bishop e7 and f5 and Knight f6
back quite a funny regrouping
so let's just put it on the board
something like something like this the
white often plays something like this
and now f5 and night oops Knight to f6
not to e6 whoops oh I didn't want to do
that it's funny f5
yeah not f6 that's what I meant
Bishop g5 yeah this is a rare line which
frankly speaking doesn't lead to much
and they have been some some really
offbeat tries here King edge 1 is 1 1
move which has been tried by bent Larsen
always an inventive thinker um yeah it's
not not so clear what this what this
move is doing really um one idea can be
to play g4 after some preparation and
also Nigel one can be an idea
so no tonight avanti to put 2 but 2 G 1
yeah it is playable it's not not a bad
move but you cannot really expect to get
anything anything right here also h4
husband a form has been tried quite a
bit and it's not so bad one ideas at
some point to play ok 3 using the
third-ranked
so um this kind of moves um yeah you
should study briefly if you play this as
black but you get them really really
rally
um the three moves slightly to not you
wanted before I really the move that you
get and more than ninety percent of the
time so yeah quick overview if you are
white you need to be aware that in all
lines here you will get attacked on the
on your King and you need good defensive
skills and nerves too to play those kind
of position in comparison the before
line is the line where yeah where this
kind of attacks on your king happen
happens young with the least frequency
so to say as only this ninety seven is
really so uncompromising on ninety eight
and then you don't have much choice you
need to push him if you play Knight II
one Bishop III up so this was too much
I'm sorry I just if you play this one
and this should be three you need to be
aware that you will be mated quite often
but when often on the Queen side so it's
very risky the night do you want Bishop
d2 I think can we recommend it to two
too many players it's still a bit risky
as black will get the attack but it's
fairly solid with 93 to F - you have
good defense of possibilities and you're
always better on the Queen side and I'm
sorry I need to put this on the board
again quickly yeah and then 92 yeah this
is a bit of a middle-of-the-road
approach um
it's some pretty interesting leading to
a positional fight but so after 97 98
you will get get the the race position
since nothing you can do so I'm out in
all the
this classical mainline is a good choice
um for four players on the white side
who believe in their positional
advantages and they're not afraid of
this attack and black of course yeah
you're playing the Kings Indian you you
know that you run you run a huge
strategical risk on the Queen side very
often you will yes simply get torn apart
there but you'll have fun
most an epic dynamic am
counter-attacking
possibilities against the king and very
often you wouldn't memorable games with
with checkmates and you simply need to
be aware this is not not in any way a
playable opening if you want if you need
to draw or want some some solid position
or whatever it's simply the most
uncompromising fight you can you can
think of yeah I hope you enjoyed this
overview I really only touched the
surface here some this is a very
complicated line and can easily be
explored over hundreds of pages if you
look at this in a book so yeah thanks
for watching I hope you enjoyed this
overview and I'll be back soon with new
videos in the series but also on other
subjects